en france encore beaucoup d'émotion ce
matin au lendemain de la mort du
chanteur mano solo cet artiste écorché
vif atypique qui luttait depuis plus de
25 ans contre le sida une lutte dont
celui qui était le fils du dessinateur
cabu et est devenu l'un des symboles
malgré lui
il avait 46 ans eric torna et laurent
sourds entre la peinture et la chanson
il avait fini par choisir la deuxième
voix une voix déchirante une gouaille au
service d'un engagement
un écorché vif qui d'emblée retenir
l'attention
on est tellement habitué à entendre de
la soupe entendre des choses justement
calibré pour un certain public
on est tellement habitué à entendre des
gens qui s'expriment pas si ni sur eux
mêmes nés sur leurs voisins que moi j'
apparaît comme un comment comme un
enfant sur des porcs
au milieu des années 90 sa plume acérée
sur des rythmes afro latino préfigure de
ce qu'on appellera la nouvelle scène
française
[Musique]
ces textes ne cache rien de ses errances
qui lui laisse dans le sang une trace
indélébile le sida son combat depuis
vingt ans et la scène comme thérapie sa
façon à lui de sensibiliser le public
complémentaire des organisations
militantes
j'ai un autre fonctionnement chez c'est
à dire qu'on est complémentaire il
provoque pour choquer les gens qui est
vraiment ne serait pas sentis concernés
du tout du tout et moi je préfère les
amis à moi pour avoir une une
comprenette plus plus profond voilà il
nous cachait rien ça nous montrer
quelque part à quel point le sida
pouvait être violent s'imagine parfois
aujourd'hui que c'est une maladie
bénigne
il nous a tout dit et donc cette parole
a été a été forte
et puis voilà je dis a malheureusement
aujourd'hui pas beaucoup d'autres voix à
part charlotte valandrey dans ce milieu
là
ce onzième album studio était sorti cet
automne son titre rentrer au port
ils étaient venus le présenter sur le
plateau de ce soir ou jamais sa toute
dernière apparition en fin janvier mano
solo devait être sur la scène de
l'alhambra à paris mais celui qui disait
travailler sans cesse dans l'urgence
pour aller plus vite que la mort a fini
par se laisser rattraper
[Musique]